hello and welcome to this video playing
again the man from the Netherlands yeah
what is he playing the card variation
where I'm transposing I'm playing in a
maraca see bind style I think this is
one of the strongest lines against the
bureaucracy point I'm sorry against the
e 6 a-6 line and so what is going on
here said actually a good move order
here for him yeah anyway I'm going to
play usual stuff to go to see one or two
d1 probably to see one
this is standard setup for white white
is going for a 45 and he's going for
this counter play here was a c4 should I
have prevented that maybe maybe I should
have okay whoo ok I played it at too
quickly maybe night a to a Scot pika
Scott defife potentially which is a bit
annoying I have 24 though maybe this is
the solution to this just attacking b6
and it looks a bit we at this move looks
a bit minute okay so he's out for Bishop
f6 it looks like it'd be sure six okay i
have f form but then the tanks maybe I
could have played 996 I would have taken
b6
wow that's very complicated hmm should
have six is a bit of an issue here
really I cool things he has spent 20
seconds for this 20 bloody seconds just
as such an easy game you know you can
play every move in a second and you're
still genius anyway so let's see how bad
this really is I think it could have
been worse to be honest I think it could
have been worse but okay not not sure so
he's playing t5 here okay I cannot do
this into place five unfortunately hmm
should everyone is going Queen a seven
okay not happy here about this
Jim I don't know maybe yeah maybe this
was the best that he had maybe there was
something bad would have tried for more
let's say with black but maybe maybe he
is totally totally cool here I can take
on a six I don't know if this is a good
move though based on the liability is
there but okay maybe I can smoke on
spawn so that [ __ ] back so the same um I
see genius a place every move instantly
and they're good I move this a 5 is
hanging curve that's good what's good
flame
I have no wait I wanted to save this
piece here absolutely no way this one
may be can it still looks like I should
lose some stuff takes rook c8 doesn't
doesn't help any place create a seven
probably as mentioned he played this
extremely well no I play it badly
whatever probably both react when a
seven I mean I don't really have yeah
I'm not when you win you for maybe have
to do this now this is looking more than
shaky and I have 19 seconds
this is the biggest problem I mean the
position might be might be just lost but
the this the the lack of time is very
very 'some tweenage for maybe ha as
check on sue phone ok now I was bound to
blunder something ok it doesn't take it
it probably is lost anyway I could have
taken before actually and win maybe ok
he knows he's been in one time so it
doesn't really look anymore
unfortunately he could have taken before
them he won was covered
yeah probably many things will do the
job here
yeah whatever
ideas looks you for that anyway I am 1x5
time yeah that was just a just a
terrible game what's that to draw a Miss
97 or whatever that was just just plain
terrible so g how can you put up this
this Hedgehog I mean this is not a very
good Hedgehog and it's well known that
it's not so great anyway I did not
really do it correctly so let's see what
did I do wrong probably it's a it's a
timing issue here 95 is coming so i have
to deal with this somewhat differently
maybe this was just not well timed the
general idea is a4 a5 um i don't know i
don't know what what the timing with the
correct timing is they cannot trust the
engine all that much maybe rupee one
first maybe this one first down that the
queen is on be aid does this form of the
edge shop nowadays doesn't really enjoy
a really good reputation because of this
Queen side build up but it's still you
have to be precise i sorry I after I
should fire up fire up the the engine
yeah he played Bishop everyone now yeah
I know I cannot do can do all kinds of
standard moves and it's the same it's
basically the same same thing maybe this
first is indeed an idea I am put more
pressure on v6 makes it more difficult
for them to play 95 I also like the baby
one more probably the timing here is
just not not good young this and yeah
Bishop f6 was better he played instant
moves anyway it is this concert me a lot
more but yeah I have to go here and then
this and this is just bad ok so here
things are things are unclear somehow
d5 yeah I know we got wild complications
and he really played every move
immediately yeah I mean and it all
worked it all worked fine take sticks
and now i played this Bishop a sick
stuff hot this this and now this again
instantly Bishop c5 I mean I had to find
all those only moves Bishop c5 hi it
seems to hold at least and now just
bishop everyone yeah I could have just
retreated this I will sing him to go to
go here yeah I think he should take and
go here that was what was what i was
thinking i 94 queen deforest i'm working
this this this when they're must be must
be winded okay bye now he knew that he
will win on time and he didn't pay any
attention and he blundered the night
later but here i can just take the night
now but he will win on time I mean this
is what what my time management led to
can I didn't do that right i mean the
the the real cause of this was the the
bad opening player from here then I then
I went for this a 4 push too soon that
was the real problem because then he got
all this count to play with 95 and so on
I have to have to do this do this
differently yeah he moved that yeah you
can you can do all kinds of things say
this is also a possibility in some cases
c5 is an idea especially if the book is
on b1 then then c5 can be can be an idea
it is a fairly standard position
nowadays you don't see that all that
much because people normally go for
hedgehogs only against one c4
three because this is believed to be
better for white which is probably well
true but it's not easy to play not so
easy to plant the thing is you see a
black can play all these moves just
immediately and this is a huge advantage
from a practical point of view for the
set up special name blitz you can put
this one in 15 seconds and I have to to
think about things I took ridiculously
long in one in one moment near this
Bishop c5 maybe clot that was that that
was that took really a really no crime
and thi go Bishop everyone maybe I have
some chance is still to to hold this and
with the time I mean the position is
equal but maybe 40 seconds that's born
in line but them yeah I have to play the
opening better that really led into the
big problems there ok guys thanks for
watching